i see our role here in israel as being
very specific around helping
entrepreneurs
parlay their successes here into global
activity
so we know that that one of the things
that israel does uniquely well
is identify great technologies but then
also understand that the market is
elsewhere and help
bridge over to that welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
today we're going to meet someone who is
deeply influential in the israeli
ecosystem
working with a lot a lot of startups
especially in their early stages meet
yonit sirkin
managing director of mass challenge
israel you need to spend her career
supporting innovators and connecting
networks first in the public sector as a
member of mayor michael bloomberg's
economic development team
and then as an investor and executive
today she is the managing director of
mass challenge israel
helping startup founders and other
stakeholders build groundbreaking
solutions
you need goal of circan welcome to 20
minute leaders master
challenge israel how you doing that's
right it's good to see you it's good to
be here michael i'm doing well
thank you for having me thank you for
coming to the show uh we have a lot to
cover
uh a lot a lot to cover so so i'm going
to get
right in there math challenges are
almost challenge is one of the biggest
organizations in the world when it comes
to the association of startups and early
stage startups and accelerators
and and today we're going to be focusing
on this concept but also
thinking more critically about the
israeli ecosystem and where it's headed
and what we're seeing so
you need to tell me in a few words your
entrance to mass challenge because you
were also in venture capital before
and you've done quite a few things other
than that absolutely
so i actually i have this unique way of
that i got
involved in the tech ecosystem at all i
um after i finished
uh graduate school actually while i was
in university i worked in a campaign on
a political campaign
and it was mike bloomberg for mayor he
was running for mayor for the very first
time in 2001 i had just finished my
freshman year
of university at johns hopkins and i got
into it for all the wrong reasons it
seemed like it'd be fun i wanted to be
in new york
seemed like a good way to spend my
summer it wasn't a really very well
thought out
process but once i started working on
the campaign i just met
incredible people i met some of the
smartest most driven people
that i've ever met still and i sort of
fell in love with this candidate this
person who just believed that he could
make
changes in the largest city one of the
most complicated cities
in the country in the u.s and so i
stayed in touch with the
with the campaign and with the
administration once i went back to the
university
and after i finished graduate school i
joined uh his team
on the economic development team so i
first started as a spokeswoman for the
new york city economic development
corporation
and ultimately joined um the city hall
staff
and and finally was the deputy chief of
staff for economic development
i give that long background because
that's actually the point at which i met
tech and vcs at all my background had
been sort of public service
i had a degree in finance and in
international relations
but i hadn't worked with vcs or with
venture beforehand
and following the 2007-2008 financial
recession
we in the city understood that we need
to we need to help
what were then small businesses or
startups grow
so that they would establish the new job
base the new job creation base in the
city of new york
and for me as a young person on the
economic development team
part of my role was to get to know
startups to get to know founders to get
to know investors and see what it is
that they need in order to
better grow better connect and i just i
just really was
enthused and excited by people who come
together
who see intractable problems and think
that they can actually solve them like
that audacity is just fascinating to me
um and so when i moved to israel in 2010
i just i knew that this was the place
that i wanted to be i had the fortune to
join
a um to help found a uh a fund that was
looking at
investing at his written israeli
companies that were going to be doing
business throughout
the broader middle east um a fund called
amelia then moved over to moonscape
where i was doing corporate
investing and there so much of my work
was around helping our portfolio
navigate within the corporates that we
were that we were supporting so
you know we had on the one hand um large
companies that are interested
in technology and want to work with
startups but they work at a different
pace
they have a different language um they
they just had they have different kpis
than the startups with whom they're
looking to
to work and i found myself at this sort
of intersection helping navigate
between these two worlds um and it was
then in 2000 like 2015 early 16
that i was approached by john harthorne
who's the founder of mass
challenge who said look we're coming
we're coming to israel
and we this is where we sit right we sit
at the place where we help
entrepreneurs and founders get to their
next step by connecting with an
ecosystem of stakeholders and those
include
corporates and academia and government
and
uh and investors of course and the like
and for me this just felt like the
natural next step
having sat in a few of those seats
around the stakeholder table
to actually now be able to be on the
side to support entrepreneurs and give
them the toolkit that they need
in order to to grow so i joined the mass
challenge team as we were being founded
here in israel
um and then i've had the great fortune
to lead the team now for the last
three years and what we do is um
is work with entrepreneurs and with
innovators in other
spaces we don't believe that it's only
founders who uh who can bring about
really
incredible innovation and new
technologies
but we work with founders in order to
help them grow their businesses
get to new markets create jobs
and build strong sustainable startups
and so we've been able to do that out of
jerusalem now for the last
six years we're now in the midst of our
sixth cohort
and it's an exciting it's an exciting
job one of the best jobs in the world
every day you get to
work with new companies and see founders
who are taking on some
pretty miraculous solutions to make our
world better
incredible and i actually visited the
mess challenge offices in mexico
about a year ago i guess and it was it
was phenomenal
and it was inspiring to see what's
happening there in a few words
what is the responsibility that you see
for yourself or from mass challenge
within the israeli ecosystem
you touched on that a little bit but but
what what role really do you play within
you know all this
crazy stuff that's happening here yeah
you know the israeli ecosystem is so
unique um and you mentioned our
colleagues in mexico we have
offices in seven different cities around
the world and each one of them is is
um sort of finds with itself within a
different mix and within a different
sophistication of the ecosystem and
growth of it
i see our role here in israel as being
very specific around helping
entrepreneurs
parlay their successes here into global
activity so we know that that one of the
things that israel does uniquely well
is identify great technologies but then
also understand that the market is
elsewhere and help
bridge over to that because mass
challenge has this pretty incredible
network around the world
i think we're uniquely positioned to
help entrepreneurs do that do that
thoughtfully by connecting with
the types of either customers or
stakeholders that they need to to work
with in order to ultimately grow their
businesses
to other markets i will say that we also
i think
have uniquely been in a place here in
israel where we invite entrepreneurs
from all over the world to join us here
so the mass challenge israel program is
not only israeli
in fact about a third of the startups
that we're working with come from
outside of israel
they come to israel or through israel in
order to connect with the local
ecosystem
and then they'll grow to other places
and that's a pretty unique place where
we actually get to introduce
foreign entrepreneurs or foreign
founders to
the incredibly deep strong
local ecosystem and one frankly that's
very
um very engaged and volunteerism
meaning that we see so many
ceos heads of funds people in really
meaningful positions who volunteer their
time to work with
early-stage entrepreneurs um it's
something that i think is israelis we
sort of assume
is part of um the culture everywhere but
it really isn't and that's a it's an
important note to make that one of the
one of the engines or one of the the
things that are keeping this this engine
going really is the spirit of entre
of um volunteerism and willingness to
support one another
incredible and so as you're as you're
watching a lot of these founders grow
and
a lot of these entrepreneurs and you
know the ecosystem develop over the last
few years and we're seeing the existing
developing in quite significant ways
what are some places where you pinpoint
some important
notes where you feel like like these are
the important things to be able to
to work on with these startup founders
that perhaps they're they're not
perhaps cognizant of as they're going
about their journey
well it's very funny we do um we do
meetings with each one of the startups
that get accepted to the program
and it's almost 50 so it's a lot of
meetings before they start
in order to try to set up what their
kpis are what are they thinking about
and our first meetings almost
exclusively
talk about fundraising right everyone is
sure if i just find that
check i'm ready to go and i know exactly
how to build the company i know exactly
how i'm going to market
i am ready to go tomorrow there's just
this one little thing missing
and then when you actually sit with
founders and you you take that apart you
sort of unpack what that is and say well
how can we actually build not just a
product or a technology but a
sustainable business right we're not
building a
a rocket ship ship sending it off and
then
going back to our daily lives the idea
here is to build a real solution
that's going to take us from point a to
point b and that requires
um requires advisors it means building a
team
it means building a product offering it
means understanding our customers in a
really deep sense
and those are all things that we help
support them on and one of the things
that we
have seen over the course of the last
several years but particularly i think
this is
exacerbated or or quickened by
the corona virus and sort of the
lockdowns around that as well as the
conversation that's happening
in many countries in the west about
diversity about inclusion about
access and opportunity is that in order
to build strong
sustainable companies strong companies
for the long term we need to
start helping our founders understand
what that means in terms of tea makeup
in terms of access to customers and we
need to understand that now
even when it seems sort of very far away
we need to start getting that
conversation happening today
because that's going to ultimately help
them grow into more attractive
sustainable businesses for the for the
future
we know that in the u.s there are many
funds that
will only work with startups that have
esg goals we know that there are
that the public markets are expecting uh
companies when they get to that stage to
have
um to have uh um matrices
around and real measurement around
around those goals
um and that's the sort of thing that's
really hard to
sort of add on afterwards but if you've
got it built into the
into the recipe and built into the
business from day one then you're really
well prepared and well positioned
uh for that sort of growth and that's
the sort of thing that we want to
introduce to
to startups through the program where
we're actually bringing sort of global
best practices to israel and then
israeli best practices to the
world and it's a really wonderful
conversation that happens between those
two
to ultimately help these startups just
get big
significant and do more more quickly
and so how does that tangibly happen in
the end because you know
these are not trivial things to to
understand or to strategically
work through as as a star positions
itself to grow so how does mass
challenge
sort of interjects itself within the
startup life cycle and help
think critically through these esg goals
or or this type of growth
so masschallenge really does take a
community-based approach to everything
that we do
we work at scale that means at any given
point we're accelerating
40 50 companies that's a lot it's more
than any other accelerator in the
country does at any given point
and what that means or what that
requires in order to actually facilitate
is a real
community approach so we work with
volunteer mentors and experts
not only from israel but from around the
world who come together
on a weekly basis to work with the
startups this isn't a one-time we'll
chat and then i'll
leave but rather work over the extended
period of time in order to help support
the startups so that they can develop
those goals those those criteria and
think critically about
the way their companies are ultimately
going to grow and go to market
we also work with the startups we bring
um
10 startups every year to the us where
we're actually building out a curated
roadshow for them and the idea here is
that we can actually be
that supporting network to identify the
types of folks who can help them get to
that next milestone
and do so in a way that's really
responsible and sustainable
right and so tell me about your you know
your passion within mess challenge and
and the impact that you're personally
experiencing one of the things that i
enjoy most in this show is also
understanding the the motivations behind
people and why they do what they do
so you need to why why do you do what
you do you could you could your
venture capital you know bloomberg you
can really do anything you want right
now why
why mess challenge as well i think that
mass challenge israel is a unique sort
of platform for me
first of all to get to know incredible
people who are building
it's just incredible companies and um
there is
no day that i'm in the office and i'm
bored because i will meet
with one company in the morning that's
looking to solve
um challenges around accessibility to
health care
or making the ivf process more simple or
more
more equitable and then i'll meet in the
afternoon with a company
that's creating cyber solutions for some
of the most critical
infrastructure needs that we have and
another one that's that's figuring out a
better way
for um for students to be educated in
early grades so that they can
better capture math uh math information
i mean
there are very few jobs in life
that allow you to get to play
or to be on so many different journeys
at the same time
um and that's an incredibly i feel
incredibly lucky to be able to do that
and i get to do that with
a team of super driven super ambitious
people
who are just looking to support
innovation and are doing that not only
here in israel but also around the world
so for me this is really just a
wonderful
way to bring all these forces together
and i get to talk to people who
care about innovation and building great
companies and that's fun too
so looking from a bird's eye view and
you're watching a lot of these
entrepreneurs go about their journey and
you're witnessing both successes and a
lot of failures
and naturally within the industry what
what
what are some common patterns that you
may be seeing from
early stage entrepreneurs that that
you're already you can already say
you know i'm saying this i've seen this
play out a thousand times before
i i don't think this is quite what you
want to be doing
well i think first of all i think that
one of the best
markers for startups is is really the
passion of the
of the entrepreneur um i think being
able to answer the question why me
why now is just critical and
um and the founders who are able to do
that in a really succinct and
um and exacting way i think are in a
unique position
um to to really a be able to get get
traction
and to be able to to raise capital i
think the other place that we see
some some founders really shine has to
do with sort of humility
uh i've gotten the chance now to work
with uh
well over 300 entrepreneurs through
just mass challenge itself the
entrepreneurs who come in and are
confident that they know
everything have a really long
learning curve they usually get there
but it takes a little bit longer whereas
we see founders even founders who have
built
two or three startups beforehand but
understand that there's a universe of
things that they may not know that they
don't know
those tend to be the ones that one learn
more quickly
but also bring about bring around them
a team of folks who are passionate and
want to support and are doing are doing
that sort of um
incredible teamwork and and i think that
that's been for me
a new i don't know if it's new but um a
really important mechanism to really see
how the the personality and the
um and the founder affect that and i
don't think that's in any way
taking away from passion and drive i
absolutely think that
that founders need to be irrationally
passionate and driven
about their companies if they were
rationally driven about them
they wouldn't be doing it because we all
know what the numbers look like and we
all know what the chances are
if you are looking at purely rationally
then find another job
but in addition to sort of the
irrational passion having a sense of
sort of humility
and ability to to learn and desire to
learn i think is
is irreplaceable amazing and so
do you see any shift in the
entrepreneurs over the last couple years
as we're saying
you know the the startup nation moved to
scale up nation are
are things changing also in terms of the
mentality of the entrepreneurs
from your perspective so i think there's
absolutely changes going on
the first um has to do with sort of age
and maturity i think we are seeing
founders who have um gotten several
years of work experience beforehand and
are then going out on their journey
um as opposed to perhaps i think our our
expectation was that
most founders were really young directly
out of the army or directly out of the
university and we're going to go launch
launch companies we're seeing that
actually grow a little bit so we're
having a
slightly more mature uh startups that
are or some
more mature founders who are applying um
that's number one
number two is a real um
profound understanding that they're
looking to build companies
not just startups that are gonna grow to
some sort of
um milestone and then perhaps look for
for an exit or for an acquisition um
that
that's not to say that all startups are
going there but i think there's an
there's a in the last five years we've
just seen so many more
israeli companies that have reached
growth level in that in that scale
um i mean just in the last couple of
months seeing the number of
israeli companies that have gone public
uh in the state just it's it's
mind-blowing
and it was not uh it was not the
standard even just two three years
ago and i think that that has uh is an
indication of the maturation
of not only the local market but also
the local entrepreneurs
um and and that makes things uh that
that makes the
ultimate goal for so many of the
founders look a little bit different
a hundred percent yonita for coming here
this was
my pleasure really really lovely i
really appreciate it i have a few more
questions not about math challenge
okay about but about yourself and i want
i want to take you back
all the way to your childhood what
fascinated you as a kid whether it's a
subject in school
a passion hobby of yours so when i was a
kid
um i had two dreams i had two plans they
weren't dreams i had plans
um the first was to be an olympic figure
skater and i
very much believed that this was going
to be my future uh when i was
uh when i was nine or ten years old
um i my family moved back to the united
states
and i saw the 1992
um olympics and i remember as a kid
waking up to watch christie yamaguchi
figure skate and i said this
this is what i'm going to do and my
parents were
totally not into it and were like
there's no way you're going to actually
do that
um fast forward 10 years i spent 10
years figure skating competed as a
figure skater
my first jobs were as a figure skating
instructor
and which i have to say if you are in
college and you need to find
a job to do this is ace this was an
awesome job to have
while i was at johns hopkins i would get
up in the morning
roll out of bed go over to the rink work
with a bunch of kids to help them learn
how to skate
and then get to class and it was it was
awesome that was a really great
great time and now i get to try to do
that with my own kids which is not going
quite as well as i would have hoped but
wonderful and a role model
some some some inspiration along your
journey professionally or personally
as you go through your path well i think
i mentioned this when i when i
talk about sort of going to the the
campaign but i just think that there is
i had this incredible opportunity very
early on in my career
to work with people who were so much
smarter
so much more driven so just knew so much
more than i did
and i just think that a day that you go
into the office and that you're blown
away
by the wisdom um and tenacity of the
people that you're working with
is just a great day um so for me that's
been
that's been a sort of sense of role
model that you want to work with people
who drive you who push you to do better
because they're just so
outstanding um and this is one of the
things that when i think about sort of
what does my leadership look like what
is
what is building or leading my team look
like i want to create an environment
where my team get to be shining stars
and
driven and and see that accomplishment
every day
um and and hopefully i get to do that a
little bit at mass challenge as well
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um so i i think of myself as being
somebody who's
uh on the all about balance right so on
the one hand very driven
and also uh like to sort of take my time
and understand things i'm trying to make
an impact
uh and and change realities but also
recognizing that as a team we work much
more
you know much more significantly
together rather than trying to really go
it alone and make that impact and
and lead that flag um and i
am ultimately about creating um networks
and bridges
i think as somebody who grew up in two
different places in the u.s and in
israel
um i naturally am driven in that and
sort of connecting around
ecosystems or communities or or
countries and i just think that that's
um that's really the way that we grow
this globe is more connected today than
ever before and that's
the only direction we're going is is to
be more connected and i think that the
ability to
um to think about networking and to
think about
parlaying experiences over different
geographies is
ultimately something that i'm passionate
about and also something that's going to
drive growth for the future
more than three words but thank you i'll
take it this was amazing
stay safe and stay healthy and i can't
wait to continue following mass
challenges around
and the rest of the amazing things
you're going to do really inspiring
thank you very much
right back at you thank you so much
michael bye thank you
you